hello there game developers have an
astounding ability to add the smallest
of details many of us miss well not
today as we are celebrating the amazing
attention to detail in video games like
this ambigram in grip a game about
Vehicles which can drive upside down so
the title can also be spun around and it
reads the exact same amazing did you
ever use the selfie camera in Watch Dogs
2 should we whip it out there's a chance
that pedestrians in the street will
photo bomb you there's even a trophy
gained from it
not all we'll be happy to be in your
selfie watch yourself drive somewhere to
be but many are down for a pick and some
take it too far oh oh okay over in
Guardians of the Galaxy we can visit the
floating head of a Celestial known as
nowhere this is a peaceful place and
weapons are not to be used here but
should we try and take out our Firearms
this will happen
you
hello yeah Star Lord uses his finger
guns complete with sound effects like a
six-year-old
you never change bro over to the Sandy
deserts and blistering heat of
Assassin's Creed Origins should you
venture away from the moisture and into
the sand dunes of No Man's Land
something very strange will happen to
bayek he will see a mirage in the
distance which of course isn't there
really the longer we wander around out
here and the more hallucinations pop up
from Biblical plagues to fish flopping
around in the middle of nowhere things
will go so badly out here that a Sandy
vision of a man will be seen walking
across the desert who also appears
behind us on a camel and here's where it
all makes sense all these things are
reported to have been seen by real
people in real life who have walked
across the desert and I know people who
have over 100 hours in Assassin's Creed
Origins and haven't seen any of these
game devs are amazing in many open world
games we use Vehicles which can be
blocked off and hard to get out of most
games add the ability to get out of the
passenger side or if they're a bit lazy
we tend to teleport out of our vehicle
while sleeping dogs made sure that
detail was covered if both sides of a
car are boxed in Wei Shen will get out
another way
yeah who needs a Wintergreen the only
problem now is he can't get back in
again the only other game that can rival
that depth of detail is Red Dead
Redemption 2. when visiting the railroad
and its construction take the time to
watch the workers in particular look at
the spikes they are really going into
the railway sleeper I'll speed this up
now but look the
literally going in and once the work is
done these guys will go and take a break
ready for the next lot another Rockstar
Theft Auto 5 has many satisfying details
which players never notice like this
when a character Walks Into Water their
clothes only become wet to the exact
point they were in there I did this so
many times to try and break it but I
can't it's absolutely perfect I can't
wait for GTA 6. I only just noticed that
clothing dries off in real time in GTA 5
and it released in 2013. 2022 saw the
reboot of the Saints Row Series in this
fully open world details were everywhere
it was even possible to find a giant
Jenga Monument the thing is this is
fully functional completely playable and
works quite well we use our Weaponry to
shoot out the timber which is harder
than it looks and best of all we can
reset the game by pressing a button
nearby nobody asked for this but it's
great and Django is one of those games
which never goes out of fashion and it's
not just Earth that can't resist Trends
over in the opening region of tower of
fantasy it's possible to spot an enemy
NPC proud doing this he's cranking out
the moves to size Gangnam Style and it's
strangely captivating it turns out this
is an idol animation for many of the
enemy NPCs whilst they're waiting for
battle Psy would be proud just don't get
too close because he gets a little angry
speaking of tower of fantasy did you
know the open world RPG is out right now
on PlayStation on both PS4 and PS5
totally free to play I've recently
started my first playthrough and I've
got to say I'm enjoying it the character
customization is satisfying and has
impressive depth with more unlocked over
the course of the game combat is a blend
of hack and slash with a strategy
element as the choice of weapon matters
we take into battle 3 weapons which can
be switched between freely the Synergy
between those chosen arms and Munitions
is the key to Victory put simply it's
about choosing the right tools for the
job and with over 30 weapon types to
unlock the combinations are nion
Limitless oh and I also like this slow
motion mechanic which is triggered by
forming a well-timed Dodge if this
sounds like your type of game there's a
link to Tower of fantasy in the
description below once downloaded you
choose a server to call home as this is
a shared world for example I'm on the
Europe 4 server Tower of fantasy
promises multiple destinations to visit
from cyberpunk inspired regions to
underwater Realms and everything in
between Tower of fantasy is free and out
right now if you need me I'll be dancing
with this guy
back to secret details this time in
wrestling games it's always a challenge
we set ourselves to chase down multiple
titles it's even better when the titles
we hold are in cutscenes with our
characters so aew fight forever took
this to the extreme while playing as a
female wrestler it's possible to pursue
and win five championships e each time
you do the entrance cinematic will be
updated so I created adamina and let's
see how many we can really hold one yes
two easy three nice and symmetrical four
it's yeah it's true and look five belts
at the same time it's true it's damn
true and if you're wondering why men
can't do this is because they cannot
fight for the female title but women can
challenge for the men's
sometimes hidden details are found by
doing the wrong things like this in Far
Cry 6 should we point a firearm at our
beloved Amigo chalito then this will
happen the little dude will play dead
his survival instincts are unmatched but
let's be serious who the heck found this
what were they doing they're so good boy
Metal Gear Solid 5 may be the best
unfinished game ever made and if you
spent enough time with your horse you'd
realize that it will poop on command
that's quite a satisfying detail yes but
it goes a little further than that for
months I had no idea why we'd do such a
thing and then suddenly I figured it out
horse droppings can cause vehicles to
lose control and spin out everything has
a purpose over to fortnite Now to
celebrate the spider-verse movies Gwen
Stacy was added to the game her
accompanying emote could be used by
anyone but when she has it it visually
changes instead of a smooth motion the
frame rate reduces to mimic the
animation style from the movies a very
subtle detail but weren't appreciated by
fans
hey guys another superhero game is
Injustice 2 which has a secret Easter
egg hidden in details on the stage set
outside of the cinema take a look at the
signage above the door all is fine right
away but if it's interacted with enough
times and by interacted I mean an enemy
thrown into it multiple times
the sign now reads finish him a nod to
the developers other fighting game
Mortal Kombat and that famous line
finish him is OverWatch a superhero game
I'm saying yes a tiny detail in that
game is all about treating robots with
respect if Bobby's called into action
but no one's around to shoot he'll
happily wave back to teammates and it
turns out almost all bots in the game do
this from the training aimbots to the
Giant pushbot Hello ah nice touch let's
change the tone to something
surprisingly wholesome back in Watchdogs
2 it's possible to use a remote control
car by doing this around the local parks
dogs will first take notes and then
follow the RC around totally ignoring
their owners it's only a tiny detail in
a huge game but it's so wholesome I had
to share it in fact there's been too
many dogs in this video so let's even
that out with some cat Shenanigans
whilst playing a is the feline in stray
we can knock a paint can into the
streets below and while it's being
cleaned up we can walk straight through
it leaving a line of paw prints which
slowly fade away as the paint is removed
another great detailing stray is at the
start of the game and the computer
screen which tries to communicate with
us what many didn't realize right away
is that the keyboard is 100 accurate and
fully interactable I try to write epic
game here yeah it didn't go well doesn't
a cat on a keyboard make you want to say
oh that shot took me so long well I've
officially wasted nine minutes of your
time if you're still here please write
oh in the comments I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
thank you foreign
[Music]